foreign
[Music]
to everyone joining us today my name is
Kate Getty and I am a senior director of
research at the Canadian Institute for
advanced research also known as seafar
cfar's mission is to convene outstanding
Scholars to address the boldest most
important questions facing science and
Humanity our active super Community
includes 400 researchers from 141
institutions in 20 countries our fellows
chairs Scholars and advisors are among
the most highly cited in the world
including 20 Nobel Prize laureates and
three turning Award winners
today we are going to be diving into
fascinating and important research
striving to better understand whether
appeals to human dignity really make a
difference for social solidarity and
thank you to our guests who are turning
in from 18 countries and five continents
for this discussion
joining me today to discuss this topic
are our distinguished speakers will
chemical and Evan Lieberman will who is
based in Kingston Ontario Canada is
co-director of our boundaries membership
and belonging program and a Canada
Research chair and political philosophy
at Queen's University
his research interests focus on issues
of democracy and diversity and in
particular on emerging models of
citizenship and social justice and
Multicultural societies
Evan who is based in Cambridge
Massachusetts is a cpar fellow in our
boundaries membership and belonging
program and a professor of political
science at MIT where he holds the total
chair on contemporary Africa his
research is primarily concerned with
understanding the causes and
consequences of ethnic or racial
identification and conflict the role of
democratic institutions in multi-ethnic
societies and the development of State
capacities
once we have heard from will and Evan I
will be taking questions from all of you
joining us today at the end of the
discussion if you'd like to participate
please submit a question through the Q a
function at the bottom of your screen
lastly the session is being recorded and
will be available next week on The
Secret website at cpar.ca as such you're
welcome to re-watch the session the
session or share it with your colleagues
so to start off will and Evan can you
both tell us a bit about your own work
why is the notion of dignity relevant in
your respective disciplines
foreign
yeah so I'm a political philosopher and
we think about what a good Society or a
just society looks like and
um the traditional answer in my field is
that a good society would have two
levels of uh justice and politics at one
level people would be able to make
claims just based on the common Humanity
so whenever we encounter another human
being
uh we should acknowledge our shared
humanity and respect that and that means
we should avoid treating people in ways
that are degrading or dehumanizing and
that gives us something like a theory of
universal human rights
but most political philosophers think we
also need another level which is about
something like National solidarity that
amongst the members of a shared Society
we should try to nurture a particular
feeling of solidarity and belonging
amongst those who share a common Society
so so not what humans are humans but
what Canadians or Canadians or Americans
or Americans
um and the goal of this National
solidarity is to kind of create this
sense of of belonging and and support
amongst co-citizens
so much of political philosophy has
concerned kind of the relationship and
the balance between the universal
humanitarianism and the national
solidarity but in the last 20 years or
so there's been this quite decisive
shift away from the politics of national
solidarity people have come to think
that National solidarity is inherently
discriminatory and exclusionary that if
you ask people who are their fellow
Canadians or fellow Americans the
evidence suggests that they have quite
biased views that they're less they they
find it easier to recognize for example
fellow whites As Americans or Canadians
and people of racial minorities
we used to have the hope that we could
create more inclusive National
identities but over the past 20 years
some of that optimism has been lost and
so there's been this shift towards
focusing on the first level uh going
back to the politics of common humanity
and people have been asking maybe that
should be the heart of progressive
politics just we should be working
towards a world in which we don't ask
whether someone's a member or not
whether they're American or Canadian or
not we just ask are they a human being
and what do we owe fellow human beings
how do we acknowledge our common
Humanity
um so that's that's a quite radical
shift in the way in which political
philosophers have been thinking about
these issues giving up on National
solidarity and focusing on common
Humanity
and I think it raises a whole bunch of
questions one is whether focusing on our
common humanity is actually enough to
motivate people to make sacrifices for
others but a different quite a deeper
problem I think is that it's not it's
not clear that people actually do even
recognize each other's common Humanity
there's this assumption that when we
look around the world we always already
recognize that everyone is a human being
Everyone's an equally a human being but
if you think about it historically
Humanity has actually often been seen as
kind of a matter of degree or gradations
that some groups are seen as more truly
human than others it's a very long
history of that around the world and if
that's true we've got a problem putting
all of our eggs in the basket of the
politics of common Humanity could turn
out to just reproduce all sorts of
hierarchies if it's true that people
think that some people are more human
than others
um and if that's true and I think there
is evidence for it
the next question is what could we do as
a society to enable people to recognize
our shared Humanity and that's where the
idea of dignity comes in that for many
activists and Advocates they have come
to believe that appeals to dignity are
the most effective way of getting people
to recognize and acknowledge our shared
and equal humanity and I'm very curious
to know whether that whether these
appeals to dignity work and so that's
what we were doing with with Evan
okay uh thanks will Evan can you tell us
a bit about how political scientists are
interested in the question of human
dignity sure you know political
scientists like myself who work on a
more empirical side of of social science
you know very much informed by the kinds
of questions and debates
um that that will just uh spoke of
um but but we try and focus on you know
specific cases and places and try and
and gather evidence to to
um not necessarily you know to to try
and see whether or not these things
happen these patterns happen in practice
and so just as will gave this this
overview you know a lot of questions
that that empirical political scientists
like myself have looked at is you know
what is the value of attachment to
National identities or to sub-national
identities
um in terms of willingness to let's say
pay taxes or to behave in pro-social uh
manner in in various parts of the World
um
but now as we face all sorts of
questions with people moving across
National borders and we find ourselves
with all sorts of global problems like
the climate emergency
um you know the questions about what
what we owe one another
um and how we act collectively May
demand other sorts of identities and
attachments
um and so so just as well motivated I
think we're beginning to see more
research around
ideas like dignity but I'd say that
among empirical social scientists
attention to the role of dignity and
political life is pretty recent there
hasn't been nearly as much work as there
has been in in political philosophy and
philosophers been talking about this for
for a much longer period of time
um you know a few Scholars working on
politics and in South Asia particularly
like in India have focused on Dignity
claims they're gonna be claims in
particular of of low-caste uh of society
there are several researchers now
working on the need to consider dignity
and respectful treatment and foreign aid
and development efforts so Tom wine is
leading an effort at ID insight to
really get people to think about dignity
is a way of thinking about foreign aid I
recently published a book that focused
on on what I call dignified development
and post-apartheid South Africa as a way
of trying to expand the notion of what
we should expect of the good life not
just kind of economic material gains but
but kind of respectful treatment so all
these focus on the importance of
respectful treatment
um and and and I think increasingly
research is going to ask the question
whether this idea
um of of what we owe each other in terms
of respect for human dignity might lead
to better outcomes for people overall
so it sounds like there's been a more
recent turn as you were saying in
empirical political science and that
there's sort of a longer history in
political philosophy but in contemporary
Society
um how prevalent do you think appeals to
the human dignity are by different
advocacy groups or different communities
yeah I mean exactly there is this real
tension I found when I started thinking
about dignity as a research project you
know I did I started typing in dignity
to to various political science journals
like the American political uh uh uh uh
science review
um you know to find maybe you know five
citations to dignity and multiple
decades and they were really written by
political philosophers
um but then you know typed in dignity in
you know Google Trends or in you know
various Search terms about how the use
of dignity is being being uh um spread
in common parlance and it's you know
really increasing over time
um and and I'd say for myself around 10
years ago I mean I haven't done a super
formal treatment uh formal analysis of
this
but I started just seeing the term and
the idea appearing more and more right
and and for sure I think that the the
metoo movement uh the black lives matter
movement are essentially dignity
movements
um and in various countries around the
world again in South Africa if there are
you know people here from South Africa
they know the roads must fall and feeds
fees Must Fall movements I think we're
dignity movements in India and Brazil
and so many places around the world
so many people are standing up and and
not simply making economic demands in
the face of of extreme and growing
inequality
um but saying you know what you need to
treat me and people like me respectfully
um and similarly I think you know just
as as a citizen in society and you know
at a university I see more and more you
know say letters from our you know
University presidents national leaders
um I think even I got a communication
from cfar Once stating you know in their
core values hey you know we really need
to treat everyone with dignity um and I
think that that that is a more recent
trend
okay well then it almost sounds as
though the term could be considered
nearly ubiquitous
um
will is your sense that it sometimes has
a value as a basis for legal or
political claims but not always and why
is that
on the legal front
uh it's a very interesting situation
that the the I the value of dignity is
Central to international human rights uh
doctrines and it's also been mentioned
in many
Supreme Court decisions in Canada and
elsewhere so we have a kind of dignity
jurisprudence but there is no
um you know neither the Canadian or
American Constitution contain a right to
dignity as such you can't go to court
and invoke a specific right to dignity
it's instead this kind of
background value that's meant to inform
how we interpret the idea of Rights
generally uh including and in particular
human rights
so it's it's it's both ubiquitous in the
law but not it's not exactly an
enforceable rights claim uh as such
there are some countries around the
world which have tried to kind of codify
a right to dignity but that's that's not
the situation here in in North America
but politically it's uh as Evan said
it's a very common uh term for Advocates
and activists to use and I think part of
what interested in both Evan and I is
whether you know I think there's some
context where
um
I think about the the death With Dignity
movement the you know medically assisted
dying that that's a very powerful
dignity movement in part because all of
us know we're going to get to that stage
of life where we're going to be
confronted with that problem and so we
all have a vested self-interest uh in
establishing Norms of dignity as as we
all approach the end of our life
the the more complicated case is when
it's some other group that's demanding
dignity that
um where I don't necessarily have a
self-interest so on me I may have
trouble imagining myself becoming
homeless or becoming incarcerated or
having certain kind of congenital
disabilities or whatever and so when
those groups are making dignity claims
uh the question is
uh you know when when I don't have a
vested self-interest am I able to put
myself in their shoes enough to to feel
empathy for their daily can I really see
what's at stake when they're making
dignity claims
and I just think we we you know we we
don't we don't really that's part of
what motivated the study is that we
don't really have good evidence yet
about whether dignity appeals are
effective if you like for those who
actually most need it for the for the
for the disadvantage the vulnerable the
stigmatized so we've alluded to a study
uh which I know brought you together to
sort of explore the philosophical debate
that Will's been describing through an
empirical project on the impact of
promoting human values for the
development of more just societies
um and can you tell us more about the
project itself sure though I would say
it wasn't the study that brought us
together but cfar that brought us
together to do the study so we're
grateful for that and grateful for the
resources from cfar and I also just want
to acknowledge that two terrific uh they
started as doctoral students they've now
both successfully uh defended their
dissertations pageball and Blair Reed
um or equal collaborators with us on
this empirical project and I'm going to
very quickly uh share with you all so
you know as has been alluded the the
question of the study is whether or not
this appeal to a universal human dignity
enhance a support for a positive duties
towards disadvantage or stigmatize
groups and
um you know we we wanted to really make
this a tractable study and so we had to
make certain choices and decided that
the way we were going to do it was to to
do a study on the Facebook platform
um and trying to see whether or not we
could get ordinary users of social media
where I'm bombarded with lots of
information
um to get them to think about or to kind
of make visible
um their their own attention to some
vulnerable or stigmatized groups and
obviously there are lots of candidates
out there but two important sets of
people that we wanted to consider were
people without homes homelessness
um and the incarcerated who I think we
can all agree
um are quite vulnerable and stigmatized
in American society I should say that
the focus of this study
um was all in the United States uh
Facebook users
and so here are two ads which we might
think of as the kind of control ads what
that we sent to Facebook users but you
would only get one of them
um and you would see this you know some
information you know about the
prevalence of the problem and give users
this opportunity to show support by you
know pressing like or commenting or
reacting the way we all do on social
media and so the question is would an
appeal to dignity enhance
um the likelihood of people showing that
support so now I'm going to show you the
treatment
for each of those looks like this the
exact same ads but with an invocation to
dignity just to point out hey all people
deserve to be treated with dignity and
respect and so that begs the question of
whether or not that appeal would be
meaningful to Any Given user that they
might be more likely to show support
now one question you might have is well
you know you could you could have added
any message there and that might just
have enhanced people's attention just
more text you know anything at all and
we know that
um organizations that support either of
these groups might make multiple appeals
so in
excuse me so so we added one extra
Dimension
um just in with respect to homelessness
which we think of as kind of an economic
utility appeal you know ignoring the
homeless comes at a cost to taxpayers
and so obviously various Advocates of
vulnerable groups will kind of say you
know
you should think about these the the
this group of people because otherwise
um the the challenge of addressing this
problem as I become bigger later
so the way we did this study was a a
randomized control trial
where we randomly assigned
um to 90 000 Facebook users
um from a continental United States one
of these five ads
um we did this on the Facebook uh
business platform and then as you know
it's a quite a straightforward study and
we basically just wanted to calculate
what were the responses to the ads how
did people react as a share of the total
ad exposures and compare these
um across the various treatment
conditions and and all I'm going to
really talk about today are favorable
reactions so like either a thumbs up or
a like or a or a heart you know a harder
smiley face some of the reactions were
negative and that's clearly not what
we're going for and and you know maybe
we could talk about that in the Q a but
right now I'm just going to present
these results and so the main results
were that in the control condition for
both homelessness and for incarcerated
people
um 5.3 percent of people who are exposed
to the ads reacted favorably and the
dignity condition as predicted enhanced
that response rate
um by 0.6 percentage points or about 10
percent which is a pretty strong boost
overall right if you're an organization
that's trying to you know spend ad
dollars effectively and you want more
attention you know you obviously
something like this we don't expect it
to double you know or triple attention
it's just you know a few a few extra
words but it clearly had an impact
but there was one wrinkle that we
anticipated because there's this
question of well you know is dignity
going to work for for everything and
everyone
um and we didn't think think it would
and you know what we've done in a in a
survey prior to doing the the Facebook
study was to look at perceptions of
blameworthiness right for people who are
in vulnerable positions
do the does the average American
perceive them to be in that position
because of bad luck or because of maybe
something that they did that they that
they're blameworthy for this and so if
you see here
um on on I have uh six figures here
um and you know starting from the
disabled to drug addicts homeless on the
bottom immigrants incarcerated in the
poor
um this is the distribution of responses
from from American uh uh who who uh
answered the survey and on a scale from
one to five so you can see
um when it comes to the disable in the
upper left corner most people feel no
they're disabled or not to blame for the
position they're in whereas at the
opposite extreme
um you can see in the middle on the
bottom the incarcerated that the the
majority of people feel no people who
are incarcerated are to blame for that
position
whereas the homeless on the upper right
look more like a lot of the others it's
more typical there's a there's a wide
distribution
um of perceptions so part of the reason
we wanted to test uh these two different
segments of vulnerable people as we
thought you know maybe a dignity appeal
would have different effects for these
different groups
and indeed that's what we found right so
if we just look at the incarcerated
in the control condition
4.7 percent of respondents reacted
favorably you know showing their support
for the incarcerated and the dignity
condition the enhancement was very small
and it wasn't statistic even with these
with a very large sample size not
statistically different from the control
condition but when it came to
homelessness
um we got a really big boost right uh
0.9 percentage points almost 15 percent
increase using the dignity condition so
that it really seemed to have had an
effect on how people you know that
prompted them to think you know we we
think you know we don't know for sure
seeing that a message about dignity
prompted people to say ah that cuts at
my core of who I want to be as a person
and even though I might feel
uncomfortable around the homeless
I'm gonna I'm gonna click support for
them
but then interestingly the economic
condition
um had no effect it actually uh had a
slight decline relative to the control
which again helps us to tease out the
notion that there was something about
the dignity message that was doing the
work
so um
so hopefully that was a a rapid fire
summary
um but it's a you know relatively
straightforward
um study in a lot of ways
um but we think pretty pretty solid
clean scientific you know first order
evidence that appeals to dignity really
can help Drive
um at least some kind of discursive
support expressive support
um for a vulnerable group
um that's really interesting thank you
for sharing
um I am struck though by
equal the effect is can you can you say
more about why the appeal to dignity
seemed to enhance or improve
to differing degrees the perceived
status of the vulnerable vulnerable
groups in your study
so we don't I you know we don't have
definitive proof for what the
explanation is but
there is a lot of uh evidence
that people make these deservingness
judgments that are very
moralistic about people people have a
sense about who deserves what uh not
just who needs what but who deserves
what
um and so I mean it's an interesting
debate in literature about whether this
is a particular feature of the
neoliberal age that we're so obsessed
with the question of people's
responsibility for for their fate or
whether this is a more Universal
phenomenon that people have always
um blamed other people for not doing
their share or not making prudent
judgments
but but there is this kind of culture of
deservingness and there is a
deservingness ladder
um and this has been shown it's you know
this is an American study but
um our hunches that we're gonna find
similar patterns the size might be a bit
different but well I'm guessing we'll
find similar uh patterns in other
countries that it looks like Across the
Western democracy at least there's a
fairly similar ranking about which kinds
of groups are seen as more or less
deserving of support
uh and typically the the elderly and
those with with disabilities are seen as
most deserving
um and uh groups like like the the
incarcerated are at the bottom although
interestingly so too are immigrants
um it and uh so this brings back the
question of the relationship between a
kind of universal humanitarianism versus
membership because it looks like at
least in part immigrants are seen as
less deserving uh because they're not
seen as members
um and so you know in a future iteration
of this study we hope to be testing also
on uh bringing in other kinds of groups
to test whether membership status
matters
and if I can just add add one thing you
know what what we haven't presented
because we're actually in the midst of
analyzing some of the comments and
what's Rich about some of our data is
that you know on social media people not
just provide a little Emoji or like you
know sometimes they write about it and
and clearly it's not the case that
everyone feels for example that the
incarcerated you know or to blame for
their their situation
um but but what we found interestingly
is that for some people adding the
dignity appeal had almost a backlash
effect you know where people were
writing you know did you know did the
perpetrator you know care about the
Dignity of their victims you know that
that for them it was almost absurd that
you know this ad would talk about the
Dignity of the incarcerated
um and so it it it it made them actually
Express negative sentiments in ways that
we didn't you know see
um you know for the most part when it
came to to the homeless
I also just want to remind those who are
tuning in but if you have questions that
you'd like to pose to will or Evan you
can you can do so through the the Q a
function at the bottom of the screen
um maybe though I'd like to pick up on
what you were just commenting on will
which is this idea of
um a difference between invoking the
shared Humanity of a victim and how that
might differ from invoking the shared
membership of the victim and I know that
wasn't the focus of this study but how
do you think people might have responded
differently if the Facebook ad
emphasized that it's being a fellow
American or a fellow Canadian not just
being a fellow human being
um the homeless person or the
incarcerated is sort of has that shared
membership do you think people would
have responded differently if the prompt
had been about kind of shared
nationality
so I I actually I I think this is uh you
know really crucial next next evident I
mean that's it's something we need to
study
um what previous Studies have done in no
one's done asked exactly that question
in relation to the dignity appeal so
that's so this is work we need to do but
um in in other closely related fields
around Justice and rights
um people have shown
there's at least some evidence
that
if what we're talking about is negative
rights
rights not to be harmed not to be
violated not to be assaulted
then it doesn't really matter whether
they're described as members or just
human beings
um so for example whether people should
be protected from police violence or
from sexual assault people think that
that immigrants should be just as
protected as Citizens uh even if they're
non-status immigrants that that's just a
human as a human being they should be
protected from violence
but if the question is about positive
rights that is why their eyes should be
taxed in order that this other person
can have some resource or benefit like
like health care or food stamps the the
example I have in mind was a study about
food stamps then it really mattered that
people the respondents in that study
made a clear distinction that they
didn't think the mere fact that you're a
human being entitled you to food stamps
you but but if you were a member uh you
were seen as deserving of food stamps so
I I mean that's one of the things we
want to test is whether the membership
status matters primarily for positive
rights
um and whether the the the shared
humanity is sufficient for negative
rights I'm sure I'm sure it's more
complicated than that but at least
that's a starting hypothesis
hmm
interesting
um
I'm I'd be curious to know
how this study left you feeling in the
sense of I mean what does this tell us
in terms of being able to generate
greater social solidarity or improving
the rights and treatments of different
communities I mean are you excited about
the potential concept of dignity or are
you more concerned about its limits now
I mean I I think we're pretty excited
um you know it's obviously
um you know the outcome we're not going
to pretend that the outcome is like the
equivalent of you know people donating
millions of dollars or going out and
really you know helping people in ways
that that matter
um
but you know it was a behavioral outcome
in the sense of people just taking the
time to acknowledge
um you know support for a group that you
know when you're scrolling in social
media which is a you know big part of
many people's lives
um that they're willing to to even for a
little bit kind of stand up and be
counted
um you know in favor of of one group
that they likely hadn't thought of that
that day
um so that we could from a scientific
study a simple one should demonstrate
you know some substantial evidence
um in favor
um of of you know the value of a dignity
appeal I think that that's that's pretty
useful
um so and not surprising that it's not
completely Universal across groups
either
um so so I I think that that that we are
bullied by that um because I think we
are both motivated by the very concerns
that will start it out with like you
know how do we create it you know adjust
society and how do we tackle problems of
inequality and poor treatment at least
what what tools and evidence can we
provide various political actors in the
world
um you know
like anything
a tool that's useful could be you know
could go awry right because it you could
have you know any group could now say oh
great dignity is this nice tool to get
people to have attention so even white
supremacists need to be treated with
dignity
um or even Vladimir Putin you know needs
to be treated with his dignity well you
know some of that could be you know
absurd
um but it could also become so
ubiquitous
um that it loses its meaning and that
and that frankly was one of our concerns
was like ah you know who knows if you
know people say dignity is it just is it
actually going to resonate with them or
do they see it so frequently that it
doesn't mean anything and so so this
study I think
um demonstrated that potential that it's
still at least you know it may just be
historically specific right it just may
be at least for a little bit in time
um
but but we were able to see yeah some
it's it's tapping into something that
people value they recognize they were
they respect the idea of respect
um and I think that that's that that's a
a useful finding um and it's kind of
worth exploring more both for Scholars
you know um and and for for those who
are in the practice of trying to extend
better treatment
um to the vulnerable
um around the world
but in fact if I could just follow up my
initial reaction to the findings was I
think both having an eye and Paige and
Blair were quite pleased with the
results it showed it really was it's a
very clean statistically significant
result
um
then we got the comments we got the
comments like three weeks after we got
the the uh the result the just the the
numerical results we hired someone to
scrape the comments and they are real I
mean it's probably that I'm just not a
big social media person so I'm not quite
as used to the tone of some of the
comments but man they were vicious on
the incarcerated so it wasn't just that
the dignity is I mean as Evan said it
wasn't just that the dignity appeal did
not create a more uh positive response
to the for the incarcerated but when
people did write comments they were they
were clearly provoked by the appeal to
dignity
um and uh it ratcheted up their
hostility
um and I you know why obviously we would
need a proper statistically significant
survey to figure out how widespread that
is and how deep it goes but but
um I I was really I was cringing uh
reading a lot of those comments they
were quite disturbing
hmm
um well thank you both so much for
sharing your your project and your
insights with us um we have about 10
minutes for questions
um so I'm going to start to read out
some of the the questions that have been
coming in through the Q a and just as
well to encourage others please feel
free to drop a question in the Q a we
won't get through them all but I'll pull
out a few
um and one of the questions uh that's
been posed is if not dignity what other
frames might have value for generating
support for for those who are perceived
as less deserving
not sure if either one I know Will has
good answers to that question it's hard
you know when Will's your collaborator
he's always going to have much smarter
answers so I'm going to have to refer to
him on at least this one
one of our interests was whether dignity
has a stronger effect than just the idea
of Human Rights so there has been
studies done about the effect of
naming something is a human right and
saying that people are entitled to Human
Rights and those studies are are have
shown that the idea of human rights does
not have a very powerful resonance in
public opinion
um and we weren't sure whether that's
because it's the human part of it that
doesn't have resonance or the rights
part of it
um and our our so our thought was that
people may find the language of rights
to be cold
formal legalistic
um whereas the idea of dignity might
have this more kind of emotional
resonance it might just feel a kind of
warmer sensibility to it
um and so so that that is our that's one
of our hypotheses that again we want to
test a little more specifically in a
future round that human dignity does a
better job eliciting uh this uh
recognition of our Humanity than the
idea of human rights which may be too
legalistic and formal
but as I said before I think that the
the
you know the the background the bigger
background question is for me at least
is the relationship between
appeals based on Humanity versus appeals
based on more specific kinds of
relationships
attachments affiliations that bind us
together as a community
um and so I think it really would have
been interesting to ask you know we
could have had the similar photo that
Evan showed but said something like you
know 50 000 Americans will be will be
homeless no American should have to live
like this or something like that and
whether whether invoking a shared
nationality would prompt a different
kind of response and if so
um what we know from the literature on
National identities is that it would you
know it might be more effective for
certain groups but that other groups
aren't seen as really American or
sufficiently American and so it would be
interesting to know uh under what
conditions the appeal to national
identity for whom does that work better
than the appeal just Humanity
so there are a couple questions I have
to do sort of with the
representativeness of the different
communities that you've um included in
your study and it makes me want to
Circle back to the explanation that you
gave around deservingness and ask
um
sort of about a potential alternative
explanations and I wonder about
um sort of the question of visibility or
the idea of
familiarity with or so I'm thinking for
example that it's
um
it's difficult to avoid homeless people
in our cities we're kind of forced to
encounter and reckon with their presence
whereas
um the incarcerated by comparison for
many people can be more easily out of
sight or out of mind the emotional toll
is low
how much do you think the relevance of
um or sort of the strength of the appeal
of human dignity might have to do with
our connection with these communities
you know they're already part of one
social world the the places in which we
live our everyday geographies like does
that play into this at all
that's a that's a great question
um because we're really just asserting
that the difference between the homeless
and and the incarcerated is a question
and perceived blameworthiness and and
we've some evidence that the reactions
differed from the comments but
um but but I think that that that
question you know the larger question
for this study is
um you know if you think about dignity
as like the the supplement or the
medicine that might get people to to to
do more for particular groups
um what else do you need for that
supplement to to work well and
um actually Paige you know who was one
of the the um co-authors of of uh
collaborators to say I want to say
co-author yet because I have published
but one of our collaborators
um her her doctoral dissertation is
about familiar stranger them and
everyday contact between uh people you
know from different backgrounds and if
you see them on a repeated basis
um are you more inclined to be more
pro-social towards them and and so I you
know I think that what you just said is
is eminently plausible
um that if we have a certain degree of
familiarity with
with with one of these groups
um would would we be more inclined to
recognize their Humanity through an
appeal now one could could look at this
you know I think that that's testable in
the sense if you were in an air you know
for if you looked at a subset of people
who could actually differentiate between
people who were homeless
um and let's say areas where there was
you know a lot of injecting drug users
and and high levels of drug addiction
maybe people encounter both of those
groups and they're familiar with them
but again
so the the familiarity hypothesis would
suggest that dignity would work equally
well for both of them whereas the
blameworthy hypothesis would say that
respondents would differentiate you know
that the effective dignity would be
different so I think that's something
that that we could study about I don't
think we have an answer to it at the
moment
I I would just add that
um there's a there's a big debate about
the politics of sight
um in in a lot of social movements and
whether the key to to making
progress on social justice issues is to
make them visible in some way and
uh I I think and this is a much bigger
debate but I I think that
people are losing some of their optimism
that both the politics of sight as a
strategy
um and so I I think it's the the
evidence suggests that
uh you may encounter a phenomenon
um but human beings have a remarkable
capacity to segment their minds to to
push things into the background uh to
not let what they experience in one
moment affect how they reason about
something else in another moment
um and so I mean I'm part of the
interested in this because of something
else I work on on the animal question
people you know this is famous saying
that if slaughterhouses had Glass Walls
we'd all be vegetarian I actually just
don't think that's true I I I think that
that there are all sorts of ways in
which people can can encounter animals
and yet still maintain all sorts of of
uh harmful behaviors towards them so I'm
I'm not quite as optimistic about uh
visibility and familiarity as the as the
magic solution to to social injustices
so we've just got one minute left so I
might try to squeeze in one last
question
um but so this project was based in the
US I believe you have plans to conduct
similar work in other parts of the world
are you willing to share a hypothesis of
what you might find in other
jurisdictions
well we we are hoping to to move forward
with a similar study maybe not with
Facebook but maybe you know we're still
thinking about the the modality we're
going to do some kind of survey
experiments in in a few of the countries
I've talked about certainly you know
we're going to look at Canada South
Africa India maybe maybe a couple of
others we expect that that dignity will
will have some you know political value
in all of those countries and I think
that's that's why we intend to study it
but I think you know what we're going to
try and hypothesize about is what will
talked about earlier you know that let's
say this American notion of
deservingness right I think deserving
this is as he said maybe more ubiquitous
but perhaps it won't figure quite as
prominently as some of these other
societies
um the the way it was a gradient in the
in the American case
okay well that's all the time we have
for today
um I'd like to thank everyone who joined
us online I think from 18 different
countries and I'd especially like to
thank will and Evan for sharing your
time and insights with our Global
audience please visit our website
cpar.ca to find out more about the event
series the work of our programs and to
view recordings of previous talks the
recording of this conversation will be
posted early next week we're going to be
taking a pause this summer and then
we'll resume programming in the fall so
stay tuned for announcements of CPR
events for the fall and thank you
everyone until next time
thank you thanks
[Music]